lightly fried my delicious halloumian
courgette cakes squeeze every last bit
of flavor out of those vegetables
but first i'm preparing a simple slow
roast tomato and Watercress salad
these cherry tomatoes are perfect if you
haven't got cherry tomatoes white
Tomatoes good or even just big normal
plum tomatoes lay the tomatoes on the
tray
and these go into the oven for about 90
minutes
if you turn the oven down really low you
can leave them in overnight to be honest
the longer you leave them the better
they taste
once you've seasoned them with salt
sprinkle over with some sugar
on the salt and sugar combined speeds up
the drying process because you want that
nice chewy texture and then you get
these little thyme flowers and just pick
off the buds garlic sliced
then just spread that on
now the tray looks quite full and
compact for 90 minutes in the oven
you'll see everything shrink down all
the Skins blistering and the flavor
intensifies so nicely extra virgin olive
oil that gives a nice earthy flavor to
the tomatoes
place your Tomatoes into an oven
preheated to 150 degrees C and cook long
and slow for an hour and a half
now halloumi cakes there's something
quite exciting about halloumi cheese
it's a very firm cheese and it fries
brilliantly
[Music]
fill the carrots
[Music]
great not too finely you want that nice
texture
next courgette the secret is keeping it
all grated the same put that into a
sieve
[Music]
a sprinkling of salt will draw out
liquid from the vegetables
then grate the halloumi halloumi cheese
doesn't look that tasty but once you've
got color on it in the pan it's really
really delicious now
really important to squeeze out the
excess water in the veg and we'll see
all that water that needs to come out of
there if we didn't do this it'll make
your little patties non-friable because
the whole thing starts to separate and
then mix in with the cheese
spring onions chop up the whites and the
greens
now we're going to season that with some
delicious fresh mint and fresh coriander
whenever it's vegetarian I like to put a
combination of herbs in there tarragon
and parsley minted coriander basil and
lemongrass
all delicious on their own but in tandem
their flavors play off each other
next
two eggs in
give that a little mix
add the eggs to the mixture
and then finally a couple of tablespoons
of breadcrumbs the breadcrumbs help dry
out any excess moisture mix
all the ingredients together
before you start shaping these taste the
mixture
it's really important to identify the
seasoning now
if you wait until you've cooked them
it'll be too late to adjust the
seasoning
roll them to a large golf ball shape
them it's like a little mini burger
you can spice these up with some chili
in there if you haven't got fresh chili
chili flakes and it's something that can
be done up a day in advance
to get your cakes firm and ready for
frying put them into the fridge
uncovered for 25 minutes pan on get that
nice and hot boss and wait for that I'll
get the dressing ready
slice of red chili seeds and all on an
angle into shards
then chop fresh ginger
a Sprinkle of sugar and salt
add some rice wine vinegar
add a couple of tablespoons of olive oil
to finish off some chopped coriander
[Music]
because that's sweet sour spicy flavor
with my chili dressing done I can start
frying off my halloumi cakes in a hot
oiled pan
look at that nice crisp Edge
you can already start to smell that
sauteed halloumi with the courgettes and
carrots smells delicious really
important for a nice amount of color on
them
as my cakes Sizzle away I can finish off
with my roast tomato salad
one of my favorite leaves has to be
Watercress just cut off stalks
[Music]
foreign
s
Watercress and shallot
they're brilliantly well together
shallot looks so dainty when you open up
these little ringlets
[Music]
don't forget to turn your cakes
now Tomatoes whatever you don't use just
jar them and put them in the fridge
[Music]
just drop those slow cooked warm
Tomatoes over the Watercress the
sweetness is incredible absolutely
delicious a little drizzle of age of
ultimate vinegar gives that tartness to
the watercress
Watercress is naturally peppery so it
doesn't need any pepper just a little
touch of salt
and then a light sprinkling of extra
virgin olive oil
after five minutes on a medium heat my
halloumi cakes are ready
so important to have taken out that
water
[Music]
you can see it doesn't disintegrate
and then just get your dressing take a
spoon of it and then tilt it to the side
because I want the garnish I don't want
the juice
but that does not
turn you on to become a vegetarian for
the night I honestly don't know what
will
delicious
[Music]
my crispy golden halloumi courgette and
Herb cakes with a Sumptuous roast tomato
and Watercress salad all of the flavor
with none of the meat
first a hearty starter a bruschetta with
ricotta and succulent griddle courgettes
for my main I'm serving fragrant roasted
beetroot and Thyme risotto
[Music]
but I'll be in trouble with the kids if
I don't do it but
so I'm enlisting the help of my youngest
Tilly to rustle up an indulgent
chocolate and lime mousse with crushed
raspberries
so if you want to wrap the chocolate
start breaking up in Little Bits we're
going to make the most amazing white
chocolate mousse our first job is to
bring half of our cream up to the boil
so
loud that is double cream okay so that's
gonna make a really nice rich chocolate
mousse what's your favorite sort of
chocolate is it white milk dark
um I love white milk what's yours I
absolutely love milk chocolate oh that's
my guilty pleasure is it really here we
go cream in
so that goes in there now you can see
what's happening straight away can't you
it's melting really quickly melting
really quickly so okay oh excuse me at
least your Jumper's white so you won't
spot it yeah I've got a nice little snap
in another Bowl add lime zest cold cream
and whisk until it forms soft peaks the
lime cuts the sort of richness of the
cream and that starts to make the
chocolate mousse taste a little bit
lighter
Zenith you're absolutely right next add
to the melted chocolate mixture
because I'm whisking it's just getting
lighter and lighter and lighter
have it all taste
nice yeah the line gives it a really
nice taste Tilly I need the rest for the
mousse
I need some for my tummy no come on
chocolate mousse into the fridge
our next job is to separate out three
egg whites this is where I need you at
your absolute best okay because to whip
those whites it's going to be really
tough so we'll take it in turns 30
seconds each okay you go first
10 seconds gone
come on telly
three seconds gone
20 seconds gone come on you can do it 10
seconds to go
five four three two one and change
excellent hold the ball right no no way
[Music]
you can't do that to me 30 seconds
that's the best way of whipping up egg
whites
slowly
good deal
don't look very happy in there so
contentious whipped egg whites will make
our mousse light and Airy and when
they've reached soft peaks we can gently
mix in our cooled white chocolate and
cream mixture
once the egg whites hit the cream yeah
the chocolate sets the egg whites keep
the cream nice and fluffy and you get
this nice light mousse in the bowl now I
need to crush some raspberries please
with some fresh mint
you can see all the juice coming out
now take your mousse
wow that looks really cool now look at
that down the bottom
let's Crush raspberry delicious now I'm
going to set that in the fridge if you
use the can I open the door please our
yummy white chocolate mousse will take
at least two hours to set so we can
crack on with our Mediterranean inspired
vegetarian starter griddle courgette
Ricotta and mint bruschetta
for this recipe you'll need a griddle
pan an essential piece of kit for that
char grill look
cut thick slices of chapata bread
drizzle both sides with olive oil
season with a little salt and pepper
and griddle each side until toasted
then slice a couple of courgettes
diagonally into half a centimeter thick
pieces drizzle and coat in olive oil and
season with salt and pepper
sear on a smoking hot griddle pan in
batches until all the courgettes are bar
marked on both sides
next roughly chop mint leaves and
combine with creamy ricotta cheese
spread your toasty tipata with dollops
of minty Ricotta and top with your
seared courgette
super simple and super tasty
now we're going to make a delicious
beetroot risotto I'm going to get the
shallots
just slice them in half and then just
chop them like that okay okay now I've
even made a risotto
shallots please into the pan for Daddy
add a Sprinkle of salt and pepper along
with a couple of crushed cloves of
garlic once you start cooking the
risotto it's really important to have
your stock
gently boiling away if we're adding cold
stock on top of the rice all the time it
just slows down the process
generally you cook a nice wide flat pan
if you cook in a deep pan all the rice
sort of Cooks at different temperatures
what stock is that in there dad because
that's a vegetable stock yeah because
you can't have different stocks if it's
for a vegetarian okay
I made that mistake once putting beef
stock in the vegetarian soup did you no
I didn't Matilda
I'm positive I'm joking
fly off the time how nice is that smell
s rice in
this arborio rice it's a perfect rice
for risotto now it's really important to
sear
the rice if we were just to put the
stock in without sweating off the rice
it goes all starchy so keep on stirring
for Daddy
no flambe on the risotto
to go with our deep red beetroot theme
I'm adding red wine followed by the
first Ladle of stock to get things
started now we're off wow it's giving it
a cloudy sort of look
[Music]
what's happening to the stock is
reducing down and the rice is sucking it
in that's right so the rice is actually
getting nice and plump one of risotto is
live when it's like this now we can't
stop cooking it we have to cook it all
the way okay ready for the next ladle
ready good girl here we go Ladle in
so we have to make this for literally 20
25 minutes and we're nursing it all the
way
eight words
pill them brought them a little bit of
salt and sugar yeah and a little bit of
aged by some vinegar in there roasted
them I'm a great
my parmesan
how's that Rice doing rice is doing good
no
no where you want to be now look at that
nice glossy textured rice so beetroot I
want you to put two-thirds of the
beetroot in there for me saving one
third for the top
good sprinkle the parmesan in there for
me please all over
again and then we're just going to get
some nice butter in there the butter
gives the risotto a really nice gloss
look at that beautiful
come down let it come down first
and then after Daddy
beautifully there you go good wonderful
shaking risotto should be like lava
just
flows out and then the rest of the beat
room on top
[Music]
and some extra virgin olive oil
that I'll pick up the bruschetta you
take that to the table okay
let's go die
this is my ultimate vegetarian dinner
delicious courgette Ricotta and mint top
bruschetta
anxious roasted beetroot and Thyme
risotto
and put an indulgent white chocolate and
lime mousse with fresh crushed
raspberries